i love a good psychological thriller
even more so when you throw in a mystery
and some twists and turns in it and
that being said there's nothing i hate
more than an abusive husband who lies
and manipulates to set up his own wife
so
literal worst uh when you first read the
script what was your reaction to him and
to the relationship between your
characters what was it like to
to see it on paper and then figure out
how to translate that
yeah so first um
i first was sent the first three
episodes from jack and harry are writers
and um who i'd worked with before so i
was really excited to receive the script
from them
um and i just couldn't put it down i
read all three scripts in one sitting
which is great sign um
so yeah i mean it's just it's such a
twisty tiny psychological thriller it's
very hitchcockian in its style and um
it starts off quite subtly and then the
story really really ramps up as we get
to sort of halfway through this the
series
um
so
and i think
all the elements are just so interesting
that you know something that seems
incredibly insignificant in the first
episode if you once you've watched all
six if you look back then you know that
it was absolutely very significant um so
i love the sort of framework in which
they told us tell the story
also really interested me to
meet this woman at a time in her life
where she's really lost her voice and
she's lost her sense of self and
um
she's lost herself really and through
the
journey that we go on with angela she
is almost broken down further to then
ultimately rebuild herself um
in
in some ways and be able to change her
situation in some ways
so it's just a really fascinating
character to play from an acting point
of view and also to to delve into the
psychology of her situation and her and
um olivier's relationship we hear your
character get beaten off screen which i
thought was a really way interesting way
to handle that kind of material
it doesn't make it any easier to
experience because your imagination just
sort of
is you know as bad or as worse as
whatever we might have actually seen
was it always in the script that way
what were the conversations like when it
came to that scene was there ever talk
about showing what happened or was it
always gonna be off camera it was always
going to be off camera i think um jack
and harry and craig the verisi director
and myself um
and the whole team were very much um
you know not wanting to show
gratuitous violence against women that
wasn't what we were doing you know we
were trying to highlight a subject
matter
at the same time providing a piece of
entertainment which is a very edge of
your seat thriller
um but also wanted to be very sensitive
about how he handled that so as you say
the imagination can be even more brutal
than the reality than the vision than
the visual so
um
it was important to i feel it was
important to have that scene there to
for the audience to be able to have a
very visceral experience of
in their own minds what angela's
going through on a day-to-day basis um
but it wasn't
ever anybody's intention to
make that what the show's about the show
is about actually the psychology of the
situation and it's very much about the
unsaid the unknown uh what angela starts
to discover about olivier her husband
aside from the stuff the bad stuff she
already knows
um
and so that's the side that we focused
on we needed to have that framework and
setting to really set
the um
the stakes of what angela's situation is
um but we didn't want to um overplay
that or use it in any gratuitous way
what was it like for you to see that
scene i mean have you watched that scene
yeah i've watched it yeah i've watched
the whole i've watched everything i
always watch everything once i have to
know how everything's turned out you
know
yeah i obviously like to see how
everything's come together and see
everyone's work put together but um
it was actually very um it's very sort
of uncomfortable seeing to film on set
because uh
you know there's
obviously we're still
filming the beginning bit that you see
is obviously on right and then
uh the off-camera stuff as well um and
it did you know it was a definite
atmosphere shift on set it was a very
uh it's very subdued few hours on set
you know because you are all
sat there thinking wow this this is
people's reality you know on a
day-to-day basis in wine homes and it's
a very um sobering thought and it's a
very sobering experience to
to film it you know um
and also to watch it
the character that you played in liars
seemed like you got to dive pretty deep
into someone and explore some pretty
dark material in that
and this character seems to have an even
more complicated challenging and
difficult life
how did you find the experience of
living in this character compared to
your character in liar was she more
challenging was she someone you felt you
understood better what was it like to
play this woman
um
my character in liar was very um she was
sort of i saw her as a woman
in a in a different position to angela
woman that's actually
very used to being listened to very used
to having her voice heard
has a very strong
sense of self-confidence um
is well respected in her job well
respected in her career well respected
in her life has the good supports has a
great support system you know has a
great life
um and something terrible happens to her
and then because she's striving for
justice she and she
she can't get justice and she is driven
by anger and that need for justice
whereas um with angela she's in the sort
of opposite um scenario she's a place
where she's lost her sense of self she
she's not feeling angry she's feeling
helpless she's feeling
um
you know
degraded and
she's feeling hopeless and
not able to
change her situation she's she's feeling
like there's no way out for her she's
not a woman who's used to being listened
to she's used to being ignored she's
used to being
and treated badly and
she's
she's just
she's had to accept that you know she's
had to accept where she is
um so we you know the characters are
coming from very different very
different head spaces um and i also
obviously wanted to make them very
different as well um but yeah angela is
very much coming from a place of being
broken down to to rebuild herself
um
and
that's that's a sort of very interesting
and sort of
complex journey for her
um whereas laura was very much um
you know sort of full of anger and
revenge and
fight you know whereas angela has to
really find her fight yeah
what was it like to actually read the
the different surprises
that lead to the final script i mean
once you got those
final scripts what was your own
emotional reaction to seeing how
everything played out for each of these
characters at the center of this story
yeah it was incredibly exciting and um
interesting and um
yeah just um i don't know how jack and
harry come up with the things they do
you know just they're incredible how
they um how they think these stories up
it just never ceases to amaze me and
it's always exciting to read one of
their scripts whether it's episode four
or episode one um
and they were incredibly collaborative
you know if i had um
i had an exact producer credit on the
show and craig rivera's eye director and
i he directed all six episodes and we
very uh
jack and harry were really collaborative
with the both of us if there was
anything once we started filming that we
wanted to weave in to the later episodes
or
um anything we felt was really important
or you know things that we just started
to explore on set that we wanted to keep
the through line for jack and harry were
just always open to sort of making that
all work so yeah it was just a dream
working environment really in that way
in a business that is always
unpredictable and you never know what
your next role or project will be
what has it meant to you that you're not
well you know not only was downton abbey
a successful tv series but you actually
got to make a movie and now a sequel to
that movie how rewarding and how
meaningful is it to have a project that
sustains in that way
it's incredible you know i mean
we never would have imagined starting
season one that
you know would have hit the heights that
it did and then also that we'd be
about to come out with movie number two
you know not even just one movie but two
movies so
um we're just you know we're incredibly
fortunate that people just took it to
their hearts in the way they did and
um you know to be able to work with that
cast and and some of the same crew um
over what's now i think 12 years on and
off um
it's such a wonderful experience and it
happens so rarely in this industry so
i think we all just feel incredibly
fortunate and um
yeah just it's a lovely experience to
pop back and check in with those
characters and
and to get to work with each other again
what can you say to tease what fans can
expect from anna and dates in the sequel
especially since you know we all love
your characters
oh thank you um
what can they expect i think they can
expect all the things they want to see i
think hannah and bates are in a good
good place you know uh no one's getting
sent to prison um which is good
so they're in a they're in a pretty
happy space so that's i think that's
very rewarding for the audience to see
after sticking with them through all
their trials and tribulations hopefully
when it comes to
angela black i'm curious i mean what
sort of life do you think she went on to
have after all of this that happens to
her can she just move on
does having her own sense of closure
help her do that what do you think comes
of her
well i mean i guess obviously that's
everyone's individual interpretation to
make their own minds about what they
feel happens to her in the end um
obviously she's not going to be
unaffected by her experiences you know
the reality is that um it's not going to
be an easy transition into it into a
different sort of life for her um
i don't know i i guess i haven't really
thought about where i thought she'd end
up i guess i've just i just spent all my
time thinking about where she's got to
and
and our story so um i guess i'll leave
that up to the viewer to decide
it's so interesting as the audience to
take a journey with a character that
doesn't know who or what to trust and
even if she can trust herself so
how did that influence the way you
thought of her your performance the way
you wanted to play her did it change you
know how you thought about who she was
it didn't change how i thought about who
she was it just um
made me think very intricately about
everything making sense obviously when
we look back at it and the reasons um
why there's certain points that she
doesn't always trust herself
um
and
then finding the reasons why she starts
to begin to trust herself so um it was
quite a comp you know it's quite a
complex thing to build and a quite
complex character to build but i really
enjoyed that process of delving deep
into
her mind really and and her
self-confidence and um
trying to figure out where and when she
loses that and where and when she loses
herself and where and when she starts to
build herself back up and rediscover
herself again what was it like to have
the contrast between these two
relationships and her life with her
husband and with this other man who she
knows is ed harrison
how different were each of those actors
to work with the scene partners what was
it like to be able to explore those two
very different relationships
it was great sam and michael were just
amazing to work with i loved working
with both of them it was um
just such a great experience um again
both just really collaborative we you
know it was we were filming during uh
the second lockdown i think in england
and we were one of the first shows to go
back so we were all with craig feverish
our director as well we were all
incredibly
um
positive and happy to be at work
together and um we had a relatively
small crew in terms of what you would
usually have because we kept things as
sort of small as possible i mean still a
lot of people but
um
so we had a really intimate um working
environment actually we had a really
uh supportive and
yeah and close networking environment um
which is the best way in my opinion to
work i always want to be part of a
supportive environment for everybody
um
so actually the
you know filming during the lockdown
only sort of added to that because we
really really had to rely on each other
and be a team and
um that's always that always brings the
best results i think
yeah i mean even though it must have
been so weird to film with all of those
new safety precautions and protocols and
all that going on does it also make you
really appreciate that you do get to
figure out a way to go back to work and
do the thing that you love to do yeah i
mean so appreciative i was so
appreciative to be
at work you know to be able to work um
yeah which you know we weren't able to
during the first lockdown but because we
were we were filming we were able during
our second lockdown in the uk
um with you know strict strict uh
restrictions and rules which we were
very happy to follow
um yeah i mean i think we all did we all
just felt so fortunate um
to be at work to be doing work that we
really believed in that we felt really
passionate about also because of the
lockdown you know the the issue of
domestic abuse had become even more
prevalent because
you know but those of us lucky enough to
have a safe space to
to isolate in um
you didn't have to think about how it
would feel to be in a very unsafe
environment in your home environment um
so it's
jack and harry actually wrote andrew
black before
you know covered was a word on any of
our lips but
um bizarrely the timing of it was was it
was incredibly apt in in a way because
it you know as i say that the subject of
domestic abuse was even more prevalent
um
so we felt like it was a really
important subject matter to be
talking about and thinking about and um
yeah and we were just
all sort of felt a big responsibility to
do to do the best job we could really
well thank you for talking about it you
do really great work on this i love
watching these character journeys you've
been doing lately because you've been
going really deep with some characters
so thank you
thank you so much thanks christina
thanks a lot
you